Rain World: Downpour is a game about reinventing
an ecosystem.
About how precise changes to an environment
and the creatures within it can have an incredible
effect on a simulated biosphere.
In the expansion, there are five new Slugcats
to play as, all of which feature not just
new, game-redefining abilities — but new
regions suited for those abilities, and new
creatures to test their limits.
And like in the original base game, everything
runs on a unique system of procedural animation
and AI that makes this pixelated ecosystem
feel truly alive.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
discover the hidden depths of Rain World:
Downpour.
Now, let’s reshuffle the roles of this virtual
food chain...
The first new Slugcat is the Gourmand, a rather
rotund creature that, at a glance, seems stuck
at the bottom of the evolutionary heap.
For the Gourmand is unable to run as fast
or climb as far as most Slugcats.
Even something as simple as throwing a spear
will tire them out, causing them to enter
a winded state until they can catch their
breath.
In the race to survive, the adorable Gourmand
sadly doesn’t seem like they’ll cross
the finish line.
But they have an ability that changes everything.
If you hold any two items in each hand, this
clever creature will combine them to create
something new.
Find yourself in a dark room?
The Gourmand can combine glowing slime mold
with a rock to create a lantern.
Or combine a Gunpowder Plant with a Sporepuff
to create an explosive.
Or a Beehive with a Vulture Grub to create
a blinding flashbang.
The sheer number of things you can make is
completely nuts, as this chart from the wiki
proves.
And if you don’t have ingredients, the resourceful
Gourmand can simply cough one up at the cost
of one food.
They’re the definition of ‘work smarter,
not harder.’
The Gourmand has other drawbacks, like how
they need a more sizable stockpile of food
to hibernate.
But the more you play, the more you fall into
the Gourmand’s pattern of life.
In one of the coolest tricks Downpour pulls,
you learn to think like the Slugcat you play
as to survive in the ecosystem.
The Gormand’s path eventually takes them
to the new region of the Outer Expanse, a
lush and lively environment dotted with ancient
ruins.
It would be paradise for a creature like the
Gourmand, but there are other new lifeforms
in this garden.
Caramel Lizards are oversized, six-legged
brutes that can perform aggressive leaps to
catch their prey.
They also have the ability to spit projectiles
that can knock the Gourmand down or stick
them in place.
Motivated by the promise of a tasty treat,
Carmel Lizards will use every weapon at their
disposal to try and catch the Gourmand.
And like the creatures from the base game,
these enemies are powered almost entirely
by procedural animation and emergent behavior,
which makes them feel like living organisms.
This approach is insanely cool and was also
insanely difficult to get right, according
to the developers whom I interviewed for extra
insight: Joar “Our project we set out to
do was: what if we base it entirely around
emergent behavior.”
James “We would ask ourself like: this stuff
is so cool, like, why don’t other games
do this.
And we found out — they’re right not to
do this (laughs).”
Although a challenge to develop, the tech
behind creatures like the Carmel Lizards makes
them engaging rivals to the Gourmand.
But while not a master combatant, this Slugcat
has some very ‘Gourmand’ ways to handle
threats.
In a pinch, they can fall from enough height
to stun enemies with their sheer bulk.
Even better, if you give Carmel Lizards enough
of the right type of food, you can turn them
into your allies.
For like the Gourmand, they’re fellow food-lovers.
Unfortunately, some creatures find nothing
quite as tempting as the Gourmand themselves.
In the humid wetlands of the Outer Expanse,
Jungle Leeches will try to latch on to the
Gourmand.
These green leeches are able to stay out of
the water for long periods without drying
up, and slowly drain the food from their hosts.
Get overwhelmed, and the Gourmand becomes
dessert.
This jungle might not be the easiest environment
for the Gourmand to navigate, but the determined
little Slugcat will keep hauling themselves
along.
To make traversal easier, you can get a helping
hand from the Yeeks.
These energetic, frog-like creatures are passive
lifeforms that jump around incessantly — and
if you grab hold of one, you can greatly increase
your jumping ability.
They especially come in handy in areas dense
with Worm Grass, which will try to pull the
Gourmand in to feed.
Yeek traversal is another example of the Gourmand
using their intelligence to overcome their
shortcomings.
Ultimately, the Gourmand’s journey is a
story of learning to work your way up from
the bottom of the food chain.
And if you eat every type of food, it unlocks
an incredible piece of post-game content that
I’ll reveal at the end of the video.
But the next Slugcat, the Artificer, isn’t
interesting in the joys of life.
In many ways the Gourmand’s opposite, this
aggressive creature is an expert in explosives,
able to turn any regular spear into an explosive
one, or cough up a grenade.
These weapons encourage an aggressive playstyle
that can result in you blowing yourself up,
but fortunately, the Artificer is immune to
explosive damage.
In fact, blowing themselves up is the main
way they get around, as they can create a
small, midair explosion to give their jump
extra height.
While tricky to use at first, this explosive
jump soon becomes integral to navigating the
environment, and encourages you to approach
movement with the same aggressive momentum
as combat.
But like the Gourmand, the Artificer has downsides.
Use the explosive jump too much, and you’ll
start smoking — and if you jump again, you’ll
be knocked unconscious.
Ignore this warning, and it’s game over.
But while the Artificer is a danger to themselves,
they are even more dangerous to their many
enemies.
For this vengeful Slugcat is hunting the most
intelligent creatures in Rain World — the
Scavengers.
In the original game, the advanced Scavenger
groups could be reasoned with, and would only
attack if you caused trouble.
But in this game, their AI’s aggression
is locked at maximum, and they’ll use their
considerable intelligence to try and take
the Artificer out.
As you move through the game, they’ll send
out assassination squads, set up ambushes,
and even unleash their ultimate weapon — Elite
Scavengers.
An ‘eye-for-an-eye’ response to the Artificer’s
escalation, these hunters have unique masks
and electrified spears that do extra damage.
They’re also considerably more mobile, able
to leap long distances and smoke you out if
you try to hide somewhere out of reach.
It can really feel like you’re battling
an autonomous intelligence instead of enemies
in a video game.
James “You have these AI creatures that
have their own agency, right?
And they have all of these various competing
impulses, I guess you’d say.”
The Artificer’s path of violence eventually
leads them to the Metropolis, a crumbling
ancient city you can access thanks to an ID
drone that accidently links with you.
You’re here to flush out the Scavengers,
but even while you’re on the warpath, it’s
hard not to be moved by the beautiful environments
of this region, which tell a haunting story
of a civilization that vanished.
In some areas, the technology still functions,
with rooms that continue to glow with holographic
displays, and even some low gravity chambers
home to Neuron Flies.
These multicolored drone swarms seem to store
data, and while they might seem defenseless,
messing with them is a bad idea.
For the Neuron Flies have a protector.
Inspectors are bizarre, multi-headed artificial
beings programmed to defend the neuron swarm
at all costs.
If you snatch a Fly, their bodies will flash
red and they’ll go on the offensive, flinging
the Artificer around the room or catching
spears mid-air.
And since each head seems to have their own
AI, they’re a unique challenge to outwit.
The only way to defeat this mechanical hydra
is to destroy all three heads, after which
the Inspector will explode.
It seems wherever the Artificer goes, destruction
follows.
If you continue to blaze onwards, you will
eventually come face to face with the Chieftain
Scavenger, a unique being that won’t attack
you outright, giving you a final chance to
turn back.
But at this point, you see the world as the
Artificer does, and violence is likely your
first instinct.
If you do decide to battle the Chieftain,
you’re in for a fight more challenging than
any other Scavenger you’ve faced.
No matter the outcome, however, the Scavenger
seems stuck in an endless cycle of destruction.
And the game does a great job pulling you
into that cycle of escalation, encouraging
you to tear through the ecosystem with explosive
recklessness.
Yet the middle Slugcat — the Rivulet — survives
not through strength, but agility.
My personal favorite, the Rivulet can run
faster, climb faster, and swim faster than
a typical Slugcat.
In fact, the Rivulet is so quick that they
can outmaneuver creatures like the Leviathan,
which in the base game were virtually impossible
to escape from on your own.
And thanks to the Rivulet’s primitive gills,
they can also stay underwater for long periods.
These adaptations are absolutely critical
to the Rivulet’s survival, as at this point
in the timeline, the rain comes so frequently
that the land has become a drowned kingdom
of unending floods.
And the Rivulet’s attunement to their environment
was quite intentional:
Andrew: “They were kind of the slugcat that
originally sparked off the idea of ‘what
if all these new slugcats had some region
or ecosystem that ties into their abilities.”
Yet the Rivulet is not the only lifeform that
has adapted to this new environment.
Eels are aquatic hunters that slither in the
bowels of this waterlogged dominion, and seem
to be an offshoot of the lizards.
They propel their slender bodies through the
water with their long, spiny tail — the
bioluminescent glow of their heads casting
an eerie light.
In open waters, packs of Eels will cut the
Rivulet off from all angles.
Their AI works a bit like the Salamanders
of the base game, if they had their reaction
time and mobility dialed all the way up.
But there are larger and more aggressive predators
than Eels in these waters.
Aquapedes are another major threat to the
Rivulet — huge aquatic centipedes with a
bottomless appetite.
Seemingly a relative of the flying Centiwings
that have turned their wings to flippers,
Aquapedes might make you think twice about
taking a swim…
Yet the more you play as the Rivulet, the
more navigating the depths becomes second
nature.
Eventually, you gather the courage to dive
deep into the Submerged Superstructure, a
late game region that is almost entirely underwater.
And in these recesses, the deadliest aquatic
predator skulks in the form of the Giant Jellyfish.
Occasionally spotted closer to the surface,
these gargantuan siphonophores can sense prey
through vibrations in the water.
Move too much, and the Giant Jellyfish will
send out their tentacles in pursuit of the
Rivulet — dragging them in close and administering
a lethal electric shock from an orb-shaped
organ.
Yet these tentacles have a maximum range,
and if you’re well-practiced, you can lure
the tentacles out, then swim right under them.
By the end of the Rivulet’s storyline, you
truly feel like an Olympic swimmer, and are
more at home in the water than on the land
— despite the abundance of predators…
But what about a Slugcat that doesn’t avoid
predators, but is one?
The Spearmaster is an at first unassuming
creature that pulls spear-like quills from
its tail.
When thrown, these spears can impale and drain
the life from other organisms.
And since the Spearmaster is unable to eat
due to having no mouth, leeching off other
species is the only way to stay alive.
This seemingly simple change turns the entire
game of Rain World on its head, because now,
instead of being constantly on the run from
carnivores, you are the carnivore, seeking
out other lifeforms and slowly draining them
like a tiny vampire.
Yet the Spearmaster is not invincible.
It exists in an era long before the other
Slugcats, where competition is fierce and
predators are more numerous.
And some predators are so dangerous, even
a biological terror like the Spearmaster needs
to be careful.
Mother Spiders are huge arachnids that scuttle
in the dim corners of the region, their abdomen
swollen due to carrying their brood.
Attack one, and a hoard of ravenous Coalescipedes
are unleashed — infant spiders that link
together into a centipede like formation to
attack the player.
This protective swarm can overwhelm the Spearmaster
in seconds, which is why it is fortunate that
Mother Spiders will avoid confrontations — if
you keep your distance.
But not all predators offer this courtesy.
Stowaways are near-invisible ambush predators
that impale their prey with long, fleshy tendrils
— then pull them upwards towards their perch
on the ceiling, where a mouth rimmed with
jagged fangs swallows them whole.
Battling Stowaways is exceedingly risky, as
one often doesn’t spot them until it’s
too late.
And it’s not just the Slugcat that the Stowaway
can catch off guard, as they’ll eat anything
they can drag up into their gullet.
It can be hard not to feel outclassed as a
predator when dealing with such an effective
hunter.
And there is no hunter more effective than
the Mother Long Legs.
A primordial ancestor of the other Long Leg
species, this artificial terror is a tentacled
mass that prowls the Garbage Wastes, feeding
on anything that gets stuck in its web of
tendrils.
Although unable to see, the Mother Long Legs
reacts dynamically to sound, able to lock
on to prey if they make the slightest whisper.
Yet while these terrors are virtually invincible,
if you’re careful, you can actually impale
the Mother Long Legs and leech off their energy
— proving that it’s not the size of the
hunter that matters, but the tenacity.
And the more you settle into playing as the
Spearmaster, the bolder you become — working
your way up the food chain until everything
feels like it’s on the menu.
Yet the final Slugcat is the Spearmaster’s
spiritual opposite.
The Saint is perhaps the most unique Slugcat
of all, because they are pacifists.
If you try to throw a spear, the Saint will
toss it so that it spins uselessly through
the air.
Try to eat another animal — even something
as small as a bug — and the Saint will become
sick, crawling around in a dazed state.
It’s plants and fungi only for this Slugcat.
In the brutal ecosystem of Rain World, The
Saint seems hopelessly exposed… but they
have a very unusual trick up their sleeve.
Using a long, chameleon-like tongue as a grappling
hook, they can lift themselves out of reach
of hungry mouths.
This tongue greatly increases their mobility,
allowing them to swing themselves through
the ruined environment they call home.
For the Saint lives at the absolute tail end
of Rain World’s timeline, in an era where
the land seems locked in a brutal ice age.
The Rain has been replaced with unforgiving
snow storms, cloaking the desolate remains
of the ecosystem in a funeral shroud of white.
Stay out in the cold too long and you will
slowly freeze, with the Saint becoming paler
and paler as their metabolism shuts down.
The only way to endure this forsaken climate
is to take frequent shelter.
But this ecosystem is not completely barren.
The pale Strawberry Lizards trudge through
the snowstorm, managing to cling to life.
And like all lizards from past eras, these
ice age reptiles are predators.
To catch the Saint, Strawberry Lizards have
convergently evolved the same grapple-tongue
method of locomotion, making them one of the
most maneuverable and unpredictable predator
species of any era.
Using their tongue, the Lizards will fling
themselves at the Saint, grappling onto the
ceiling next to them, or even onto the Saint
themselves.
Trying to anticipate how the Lizards’ AI
will interact with the game’s physics system
is exceedingly difficult, making them a worthy
rival to the agile Saint.
Yet even in competition, it is hard not to
feel strangely sorry for these lizards, who
like you are doing all they can to survive
in this endless winter.
These are creatures of the snow, focused primarily
on outlasting the cold.
Not all creatures are interested in playing
it cool.
In the warm-hued region of the Rubicon — an
underground locale exclusive to the Saint’s
storyline — the hot-tempered Firebugs are
quick to go on the offensive.
If you accidently startle one, they will quite
literally explode with anger, sending their
eggs scattering and careening towards the
Saint like a heat-seeking missile.
Not one to forget a grudge, they will continue
to pursue you until they find their target.
It's best to behave like a saint, and give
them no reason to get aggressive.
Yet the final lifeform is as needlessly aggressive
as the Saint is peaceful.
Swooping in on massive wings, Miros Vultures
are a whirlwind of teeth and claws that give
a whole new meaning to death from above.
A horrific amalgamation of Vultures and Miros
Birds, the Miros Vulture is relentless in
its path of destruction, moving through areas
like a living natural disaster.
If their beak that can slay you in one hit
and the blades on their wings aren’t enough,
the Miros Vulture’s glowing eye can also
unleash a laser that explodes with concussive
force.
But even this nightmare of a predator is often
no match for the Saint’s simple, passive
avoidance.
You can defeat Miros Vultures the same way
you defeat the snow: by staying calm and waiting
out the storm.
Like all the Slugcats before it, playing as
the Saint will make you think like one, approaching
all situations with a clear mind and avoiding
fights instead of starting them.
Each of the five campaigns change both the
ecosystem, and the way you think about your
place in it.
And if you fulfill all the requirements in
the Gourmand’s campaign, you unlock something
very special.
The next time you boot up the game, you might
encounter a final creature — the Slugpups.
These adorable infant Slugcats offer a new
way to navigate the game, because now, you
can be a parent.
And you can take them by the hand or carry
them all the way to the end.
And you can adopt more than one.
Make sure you’re ready for the extra responsibility
though, because once a pup bonds with you
it becomes your duty to protect them from
the dangers of Rain World, which can be extremely
stressful.
But it’s a cool hidden system, with a surprising
amount of depth.
Andrew “We basically has just one person
on the team just solely devoted to developing
the Slugpups” James “It’s a very big
project.
It’s huge!”
No matter how you get to the end, each of
the new Slugcats has at least one conclusion
that wraps up their journey in a poignant
yet unexpected way.
If you’d like to check out the expansion
for yourself, once again, be aware that the
game is exceedingly difficult.
I’ve never felt more aware of my vulnerable
place in a virtual ecosystem than when playing
Rain World — which is by design: Joar: “Rain
World is about humility, right?
It’s like: you’re not some big hero, you’re
just this little creature.”
A tremendous thank you to the creative minds
behind this game for sharing insights into
how the ecosystem came together.
It’s been an honor exploring this pixelated
biosphere.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.